- GOOD EVENING.
WE'RE COMING TO YOU
FROM THE HISTORIC ELYSIAN PARK
IN LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
NOW, EVERY WEEK ON MY SHOW,
I CHALLENGE PEOPLE
TO TAKE BIG RISKS.
BUT SOME HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
THAT I NEVER TAKE RISKS MYSELF.
WELL, TONIGHT,
THAT'S ALL GONNA CHANGE.
OVER THE PAST MONTH,
I'VE BEEN LEARNING
HOW TO PICK THE LOCK
ON THESE POLICE-GRADE HANDCUFFS.
"WHY?" YOU ASK.
BECAUSE TONIGHT I'M GONNA TAKE
A BIGGER RISK
THAN ANYONE HAS EVER TAKEN
ON TELEVISION BEFORE.
IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS,
I'M GOING TO BE HANDCUFFED
TO THIS SOLID STEEL FRAME,
AND I'LL HAVE EXACTLY 90 SECONDS
TO FREE MYSELF
BEFORE THE CLAW
ON THIS ROBOTIC ARM
UNDOES MY PANTS,
EXPOSING ME TO AN AUDIENCE
OF CHILDREN.
IF THAT HAPPENS,
AN L.A.P.D. OFFICER
IS STANDING BY TO ARREST ME
FOR INDECENT EXPOSURE.
WE'VE ALL SEEN ESCAPE ARTISTS
RISK DEATH BEFORE.
BUT TONIGHT, I'M GOING TO RISK
SOMETHING EVEN WORSE:
BECOMING A REGISTERED
SEX OFFENDER FOR LIFE.
AND WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE TONIGHT IS 100% REAL.
WELCOME TO NATHAN FOR YOU.
THIS IS THE CLAW OF SHAME.
[dramatic music]
- NOW, YOU KNOW
THIS IS CONTROVERSIAL, RIGHT?
- WHAT DO I GAIN BY DOING THIS?
- NOTHING.
- IF HE'S GONNA ESCAPE,
IF HE'S GONNA GO TO JAIL.
- I MIGHT NOT EVEN ATTEMPT IT.
HE'S TAKING A BIG RISK.